e aí galera campeonato você olha só quem
está aqui numa começar com você e eu
mesmo o irã o ensino no sudão deste
canal e você ainda nem do meu rosto foi
a desculpa de mora em gravatá a desculpa
de mora aqui uma câmera quebrou depois
explicar como seu com ela quero dizer a
você que eles são paulo e sobral no
ceará e fortaleza de teresina e matheus
mega show usa e enquanto os ingressos
aparecendo aqui na tela os shows aí pra
você que não viu ainda quer o show se a
sociedade tiver aí como sem graça ensaio
está aparecendo e nós estamos em julho
junho que tem as festas juninas festa
junina jolie que é muito bom porque tem
feriado e quer bombinha para não
estourar bombinha duas boas que criança
gosta é comer coisa escondida de
madrugada na geladeira chora bombinha
dançar quadrilha dançar quadrilha é
muito bom estar porque nas quadrilha é
que você encontra o seu primeiro amor a
mas não é a primeira morte com 15 anos
coisa no momento não não não
o primeiro foi na quadra aqui lembrei
das quadrilhas são barcos e de mão dada
com a pessoa que você já se imaginou
futuro que o cetad de de pádua que você
feito com carvão e aí você já se imagina
alguns anos a fez com que cada pessoa
seja além de mandar só você tá chato que
você tá dançando como está todo mundo
animado assim ó a música está tocando
essa e avós e avançando além da menina
assim então né
a nossa primeira mãe também a nossa
primeira desilusão amorosa que
geralmente não têm sete ano o par de
linha tem 15 e termina às quadrilhas
gente olha lá a menina ficando gordo
fininho cortado numa moto cg 150
nunca mas nunca vagabundo também
preocupa a lei do estágio
mas a tristeza passado ele que como você
está pensando a menina penso que não
venham me rouba bom para você se
espantou o lugar que eu me cobro não me
todo lugar acenou na quadrilha é do
torcedor ver top paz e noiva da
quadrilha têm filhos e kátia cabeça e
buriti às vezes você fica ser silo de
não uso esse ano você noiva porque o
vestido não é muito bem o que eu não é
que uma cena bonita mesmo não eu eu
também eu nunca fui noiva e também não
tinha essas perdas não nunca fui não é
nóis é nóis na sacada ele sábado acho
engraçado que tem um estoque no ipi por
exemplo a pessoa que nunca vai poder
dançar quadrilha na vida é aquele
repórter animal o recheado de música
aqui ó
olha a cobra é cobra é cobra cobras mais
venenosas do mundo é se você encostar o
perigo de morte olha só como ela se
despe os meus deles e passado descobriu
já não pode contar com permitem de
quadrilha que o casal sandra de sá e do
que no leste é anarriê diabo e ana rita
marrafa cidade no interior já que na
fora ou então pode não ver a gaúcha eo
gauchão sob o nome de guerra aos
embargos anos joão andré pode ser uma
menina ana e ari é presente lei que é de
80 gente os cds são joão a esse fato o
império vai cada um para evitar o
problema na subestação luiz gonzaga quem
recebe a visita do interior sempre um
cachorro atenção acaba sempre afastar
assim da estrada na hora que a gente
dobra da estrada para poder estar comum
da casa
o cachorro copa do sheik hoje por um
cachorro a campanha no interior um dador
não aparece um jovem na porta e no
interior daquelas porta grande alma não
é um
que a janela em bater a porta sempre
aberta a janela fica após embaixo de
escada de cordas e mudou a comunicação
de verbas a atenção um velho onde ele
encontrou do velho no meio da rua ele o
bom dia como é que vai não eles falam as
coisas que só o sangue tem botas a
atenção tem uns 10 mi e tv e eles passam
pelos fala assim ninguém telhado quando
você chega para complementar seu parente
do menino já ministraram o benito toda
hora tem uma boca de pedra paciência
soube eu acho que a única pessoa que
fica feliz com o seu bom bié as pessoas
comércio que vendia buggy e o [ __ ] que
não é só chorar depois de cada história
da hungria até filme tão brincando é
fácil
ok ok o burro aqui brincou o presidente
que nem com aqueles tracção taxa de
terra boa que joga noutra história perde
vertente ama também na secção de pdv que
nunca viu o psd vem instaurando aqui
minha avó e aí vou matar um pm e mais um
planeta eu acho engraçado às vezes a
gente chega no interior não sei que uma
criança que ela é mais barata do que as
outras e ela fica olhando pra gente
parece que sabe os pecados da gente
tudinho e xetá cumprimenta todo mundo na
época
aqui a gente encara a cabeça na parede a
página não para não dizer menino de
edição jogo do diabo não fala quem sabe
a sorte quando você está olhando é que
sempre é um menino e chora no bongue não
importa o local do mato que ele esteja
porque quando testou nas bobinas pode
fazer do mato vai fazer calor que fez no
discurso mas penso que num caso assim
não adianta fugir do grid longe da casa
minha vida marca tem em campo tinha dito
então de história tudo é o tata ravi a
minha aqui o tcheco
quando você se vê num teve um senhor vai
falar com 15 menino corre por b da casa
cada um com a caixa do mundo e você não
sabe que você está na casa da vovó é na
faixa de gaza não me passar são joão
mistério com um amor de menina
treinamento afeganistão não tem muito
essa música paka paka paka paka que
reparam foi um sonho ruim em bomba bomba
bomba bomba bomba ibaka catar tentados
feito e vem ataca tatá abomina a gente
sabe agora dizer pois você pode comprar
bomba que você pode comprar os fogos de
artifício que forma eles que estou no
céu nada nada se compara a você pegar um
bombril tocar fogo e saiu com dancinha o
show de pirotecnia mi5 geday meu lado
bom do botafogo sair esse ano
se você gostou desse vídeo eu quero
conseguir que gostei aqui no youtube
muito obrigado último vídeo até 1 milhão
de likes você lembrar de que gostei
então clique aqui também não se esquece
brincando porque o bota lá no facebook
deu porque esse vídeo novo são joão só
que lá a clique em curtir no facebook
isso ajuda demais mais gente circulando
por ti obrigação de insumos e vai ver o
vídeo tá mata seus amigos nos
comentários e lembrados são joão dele
mas seus amigos lá nos comentários no
facebook legal o são joão dele se
inscreve no canal no youtube e comentei
aqui em baixo como é que é o seu são
joão se você gosta de dançar quadrilha
você já se apaixonou por alguém da
quadrilha se você já foi noiva da
quadrilha que serve o canal
vou perder um vídeo novo muito obrigado
por existir se vir até aqui e é isso aí
vou comprar uma câmera para gravar mais
um pra vocês
valeu galera é na ibm quer ver falou